zum abschluss in den letzten zehn
minuten unserer sendung möchte ich jetzt
noch einmal auf zwei weitere themen
kommen die die nächste woche wichtig
werden und zwar das thema klima her
kenne da haben heute ihre da wurde heute
ein brief an die kanzlerin angela merkel
und scholz versand und daraufhin hat
sich thomas bareiß direkt eingeschaltet
der staatssekretär und hat gesagt was
die grünen hier fordern ist
sozialpolitisch unanständig co2 co2
preis von 25 auf 60 das heißt vor allem
dass berufspendler und eigentümer
kleiner für einfamilienhäuser eine
jährliche mehrbelastung von 325 euro
aufkommen müssen wie gehen sie auch vor
dem hintergrund der frage dass sie ja
mit der union vielleicht mal zusammen
regieren wollen jetzt in diese
klimawoche nun hörbare es ist ein gutes
beispiel darum warum die große koalition
so eine klatsche beim
bundesverfassungsgericht bekommen hat
wichtig ist dass jetzt das politik
handelt dass wir nicht nur die
zielzahlen irgendwann wieder co2
einsparen sondern auch konkrete
maßnahmen ergreifen
deswegen fordern wir ein kohleausstieg
auch 2030 vor zehn oder co2 preis den
wir übrigens ausschütten wollen
das heißt menschen die wenig verbrauchen
kriegen ihn also viel zurück wie alle
anderen profitieren damit wird
durchschnittlich also das hat eine
soziale ausgleich wirkung und ehrlich
sache brauchen einen schnelleren ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien in diesem land
da ist viel verschlafen worden und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn diese
regierung danach handeln würde aber was
gehabt standhalten aber was bedeutet das
ganz konkret für den verbraucher für den
einzelnen wie hoch wären die
mehrbelastung was bedeutet das zum
beispiel für die frage wie viel fleisch
jemand künftig essen soll was ist mit
diesel autos also was bedeuten die dinge
die sie vorhaben jetzt auch vor dem
hintergrund dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat und
vor dem hintergrund der des wahlkampfs
für
den einzelnen das bedeutet einmal dass
wir massiv und schleunigst erneuerbare
energien ausbauen müssen damit für den
kohleausstieg auch 2030 vollziehen kann
das ganze ist wenn das nicht so an die
wand gefahren wäre dann sehen wir dass
erneuerbare schon heute deutlich
preisgünstiger sind als fossile energie
das heißt wir können da können geld
sparen und wir sagen mit 19 und 23 uhr
sei es hat eine lenkungswirkung so ein
co2 preis und da wollen wir sozialen
ausgleich dran nehmen das heißt wir
stützen der co2 pro kopf pro person aus
so dass menschen die wenig energie
verbraucht aber was heißt das konkret
erkennbar das versteht ja der zuschauer
nicht was es für den einzelnen bedeutet
also wie hoch wird die mehrbelastung ja
wir reden wir reden insgesamt bei einem
bei einem co2 preis von 35 auf knapp 60
60 euro reden wir von jährlichen auch
ein paar euro bereichen sowohl bei der
frage von heizenergie als auch bei der
frage von den kosten und deswegen ist
also wie viel euro
wie viel euro es ist das ist nicht das
thema ist so wahnsinnig viel aber
ehrlich gesagt durch der umstieg durch
den umstieg auf aber nennen da mal einen
preis kann ihm melden also wenn melden
sie sich anschauen was ist kostet dann
sind wir bei da sind wir ungefähr bei
ärgert sich daran ab wie viel sie diese
pendeln bei 150 euro
round about im jahr herr lindner was
glauben sie kommt da auf die deutschen
zu was sind ihre rechnungen die sie bei
der fdp machen
nun ja nicht bei der fdp sonst hier
immer gerade spontan und wir alle
gemeinsam können dass man auf
plausibilität testen
der deutsche verbraucht im durchschnitt
elf tonnen co2 pro person
jetzt hat der kellner gerade
vorgeschlagen das von 25 euro das ist
der co2 tonnenpreis zu beginn dieses
jahres ist er eingeführt worden übrigens
mit zustimmung der grünen
also der co2 preis von 25 euro der seit
januar dieses jahres gilt der er ist
erreicht worden durch verhandlungen der
grünen
und das jetzige kohle ausstiegs gesetz
gibt es nur weil die grünen mit
verhandelt haben also das gesetz der
grünen auch das im carl orff es waren
zehn euro die große koalition
vorschlagen hat und wir haben dann im
bundesrat in der tat dass du sorgt dass
es überhaupt überhaupt x factor da 25
euro was ist schon damals wenig dass wie
bisher weiter auf 35 euro und wir sagen
ja auch 60 euro das wissen sie ja nehmen
wir nehmen wir zu protokoll wenn ich es
sehe ist er anfang des jahres auf 25
euro eingeführt worden und sollen jetzt
berichten im und 30 wir wollen auf 60
gehen jagen brücken auf 60 erhöhen nur
rechnungen ich weiß gar nicht bewerten
35 euro mehr pro tonne mal elf tonnen
zeigen sie uns mal einen taschenrechner
herr länder wie sieht der aus nur damit
wir sehen können sehr gut sodass sind
385 euro pro person nehmen eine
vierköpfige familie sind das 1540 euro
pro person die die grünen jetzt
vorschlagen bei 25 auf 60 tonnen co2 pro
tonne jetzt die politischen märkte auf
jeden fall werden wollten hätten sagen
sie bekommen mit dem er und dass
derjenige der ein kleinwagen hat und
lassen den punkt zu ende machen der
kenner sie können doch danach sofort
eingreifen ich habe das jetzt nur
sachlich dargestellt dass ich das
unterscheidet und ja weniger als etwa
haben mehr als elfter ob ich sollte sich
dass sie nicht in der lage sind meine
gedanken jetzt kurz anzuhören wissen sie
ich habe dann versucht es zu ergänzen
was sie gerne vergessen wollte nur das
würde ich doch sehr wundern kann das hat
auch einen tisch weiter wichtig sind
dran erinnern in ihren ausführungen ja
dann machen sie es jetzt gern ich bin
höflich aber moment herr lindner jetzt
wollen wir erst mal ihre rechnung war
dass der abschluss betrag den sie die
rechte daran
es war der abschluss betrag nur allein
und deutlich zu machen die erhöhe
und jetzt kommt meine kritik wir haben
jetzt wird nämlich gerechnet wenn ja wir
wollen das geld ja auch zurückgeben wir
wollen um verteilen und so weiter es
soll ja dann bei der vierköpfigen
familie mit geringem einkommen gar nicht
so hart sein weil wir nehmen da was weg
und dann geben wir das zurück und
verteilen um also eine gigantische
umverteilungsmaschine ich mache der
anderen vorschlag wenn das überzeugt was
der kenner darstellen wird gleich der
kann das ja machen ja auch viele wählen
super demokratie ich mache anderen
vorschlag
mein vorschlag ist wir wechseln aber ein
anderes modell der steuern nicht mehr
mit dem preis weil das hat sich in den
letzten 25 jahren nicht als erfolgreich
herausgestellt
ältere erinnern sich an die ökosteuer
die eingeführt worden ist noch von hans
eichel glaube ich da hat man das benzin
teurer gemacht wenn man geglaubt hat die
leute fahren mehr und haben fahren
weniger und haben weniger autos nicht
der fall haben nicht funktioniert die
leute haben nur gib mir geblecht deshalb
jetzt mein vorschlag wir machen ein
altes co2 limit es gibt einfach nicht
mehr co2 auszustoßen
gibt's nicht und wer ist mehr etwas
davon braucht von diesem budget muss
sich an anteil kaufen was ist der
vorteil einer solchen mengensteuerung
sagen die experten
es entsteht ein enormer
innovationswettbewerb um die vermeidung
von co2 und auf jeden fall ist eins
gesichert nämlich die erreichung von co2
vermeidung zielen herr blume schüttelte
mit dem kopf der will mit dem kellner
gemeinsam lieber die verbrennungsmotoren
verbieten
dann ist auch erlaubt ich glaube nur
nicht er steht auf der blume steht auf
der seite der marktwirtschaft
emissionshandel schon gezeigt